i mean you read 1984 by georgia where
it talks about double think and double
speak who controls the language
who controls thoughts and why he does
talk about as
they go they like eliminate a lot of
words right
now like later one word can represent 10
different things
and like what fascinates me is like how
many
vocabulary meaning people can have
and like when i literally came out i
remember i went to san francisco
and someone came to me and hugged me and
then he was a guy it's like
oh baby don't worry i'm gay i was like
what the heck is gay i don't know
right and then they try to go to hotel
and google the gay and i think oh that's
what you meant
and like that like they deny what that
is i'm sure there are gays in north
korea i'm sure there is
but you don't know what it is and
like that they eliminate words so the
fact that you know the concept
that is a state is much better than and
that's the thing a lot of people like
when you're born
you somehow know what justice is what
liberty is
and it's all somebody taught you that
and like that's the thing why
people is like oh humans are inherently
no
what is right what is wrong what is
oppression and like
no that's like bs you gotta learn that's
fascinating that words
give rise to ideas so like
as a child one of the ways to learn
about justice and freedom
is to first learn the word and then to
ask well what is it
yeah the concept yeah and if you don't
have the word for it
then you never have the kind of first
spark
that leads to you trying to be curious
about it that's interesting and
controlling the words
and then yeah i mean learning your
thoughts you control the thoughts
there's so many echoes i mean i have uh
it's it's a very different but perhaps a
very similar experience which is the
journey of my family
through the soviet union
because there is a love of country there
is a pride of the people
yeah like you are proud of your family
in general yeah
but um i wonder how much of that is
polluted
by the the propaganda i think a lot too
for sure yeah it is to this day i'm like
my father who died in china and
he was tortured and then he died
he wanted to go back before his bath
right
and then it's like that if you go back
you're gonna be executed
and like i wanna be executed he wanted
to go back to north korea
to be executed so he can be buried in
his own land
and then his last wish was if i die
criminate me and then bring my ashes
back to my country
when i'm dead i still want to be my
country
and this is a nationalism this is a
propaganda right
and but now like it's the same thing
like
it's the same thing if i die i somehow
buried in my land
and i still i feel like i'm the outsider
i'm always longing for my home it's a
horrible home
yeah like my people say what's your
dream like do you want to be a president
do you need to run for office like
i just want to go home that's my dream
right
and people here don't get it ever yeah i
um
i don't know what to do with that i love
my country and i think for me my country
is
um the united states and perhaps it will
be for you too one day
it is i think it's becoming new years
has been a very special place in my
heart
i think this is the first place i felt
like i i feel like home
and i mean i was in south korea longer
and i didn't feel that way
so so i think there were very different
life stories but
i think it's almost two different people
the for me it's the person that was in
the soviet union and the person that's
here those are two different people for
that previous person's home
in the soviet union and he's part of me
yeah
and i suppose in that same way you're
you know your first maybe two decades of
life
are somehow longing for the home that is
north korea
yeah and your next two decades of life
might be finding a home
in the united states yeah
you